you going to gym today yes yes man you
bought them I'm gonna do some boxing I'm
excited I have to cool it you bought
your boss that guy uh yeah you said the
big guy yeah the guy I did the the man
who's gay the gay gentleman here yeah
I'm in a box with him uh we're gonna
move around what you guys doing after
what you mean I'm just curious what hey
you're not setting a trap or you know
I'm just gonna like you know some guys
like when I get done Boston I liked it
I'll take a shower yeah hit the streets
and then go your coffee yeah you know
what and then I was like you guys you
get done shine yeah I'll take shine then
like you stay in the sauna yeah well so
what I'll probably do is I'll take a
shower or maybe I'll just maybe I'll
retire to the sauna
yeah retire me and then you see you
there - yes sometimes he gets in there
and you know I've never talked do you
ever kind of it's so hot yeah I bet you
do talk but does ever get like does he
make it like super hot in there yeah
I've been a lot of fun yeah it gets
super nice real hot because you want to
really have to penetrate your muscles
you asking me well just curious because
did you make it so hot really can't
really see it gets super it's gets super
super like foggy in there yeah and like
everything then you're like dripping wet
yeah you body your body the sweat just
pours off you I will say that that's why
I've given him now fulfills not even you
know just to tell am i right well I mean
if I say this no come on I've been in a
million saunas you guys did some towels
it's not hot there are there there have
been times I can trust you
of course bro there have been times
where I've taken the towel off shirt I
need to chisel he took his off he does
are you letting me down the back oh god
I knew it
Thomas or above this table oh man we're
cup of silly honk-honk-honk goose I'm a
goose Oh Hulk
sorry man I scream I have a headache
this is on enemy fighting calm eater
passed down Carrie
I mean the fruit is I enjoy for energy
it says that you made an odd vet that
Conor McGregor not only wins a couple
rounds but he lasts all 12 and the bet
is that you would bet you a dick pick
what I don't to say about that
not really escalate its price to upset
and fall asleep um
Polly just actually made Polly just
takes me we get to that um right there's
all the Polly rumors got knocked out
knocked down at least like on respond
we'll get to that I'm sure you have any
Kermit
yes alright great grand wonderful um
yeah the dick pic you know it was just a
joke as doing something New York really
escalated my mom saw that anyways I'm
just you know I think out 12 rounds I
can't bed 100 grand any more Max
Kellerman you know he's not taking the
bait he said his team said he you know
you never know what's gonna happen fight
for the judges so that he doesn't bet
the money you know I opened a joint
account put the money in there hashtag
scared hashtag the Skip Bayless ESPN but
it's whatever
so there's I'm not paying more money so
then I was just [ __ ] around said a
big bake what can he do got it chief
colleague it's not going like the third
round he said let's do the dick pic
Muslim just a frumpy old shriveled up
now the cold shower dick pic just a sad
one on top of 100 Chael Sonnen says to
flow combat there he believes that Chuck
Liddell will be fighting him that will
be his next opponent it has legs the
rumor um I mean I love Jill I love Chuck
when I watch it yeah is it the right
thing to do you'd watch it chin I would
but I wouldn't I would watch it but my
thing is with Bellator is like I'd much
rather see
Chael Sonnen versus Ryan Bader or Phil
Davis or like the legit content like a
young guy or you know build up on these
younger guys I think when you keep doing
these Jill vs. Wanderlei holy skates you
Ken Shamrock 7 you know phaidor verse
Wanderlei it almost stops your
organization from growing I think can we
take it more serious which they are and
they said that huge massacre garden card
like the lorenz larkin vs. Lima is a
real fight Bader Phil Davis you know
there's a ton of examples Michael
Chandler still needs to fight so there's
all these guys that they should be
promoting more and not have it such
legend legend you know like I didn't put
those legend they should lead the
pay-per-view like meaning they should be
the first fight and then put the real
guys who are in the primary careers as
the main event combing of it but just
don't sell it on these two older legends
fighting I'm sure it'll do pretty decent
alright yes Chuck Liddell I mean you go
down to the south and I got boys the
best ever they're watching it